Okay. Now, do you want me to answer the
question, will there be animals in the
new heavens, new earth?
You want me to go out with a treat,
which is not related to the topic, new
heavens, new earth. And do you want me
to show you from scripture? Animals are
living souls. They have souls. They have
spirits. Which is why no two animals are
alike. They have their own unique
personalities, characteristics, and why
even animals don't want to die. Let's
see what passages should I bring up.
Hold on. Let's do Let me go out with a
bang for all of you. Let's end it. This
is why you have to be young earth
creationist. So, Donna, you're going to
like this. Let's go step by step. Ready?
First step.
Animals, birds, like humans are living
souls. Now, this translation says being,
let me see if I can find a translation
of soul. Reason why I want to do this
is because it uses the word Yahweh. I'm
going to show you what the word is in
Hebrew, right? Don't let anyone tell you
no animals don't have souls. Animals
don't have No. Shut up, man. Sam, you're
you're teaching blasphemy. In fact, I
was told that you have even Catholic
saints that are known as saints
that
oversee animals and pray for animals and
love animals. Is that true? I don't
know. I don't know much.
Okay, you ready? Legacy Standard Bible
translated as living being. See brother,
if you don't go look at the original
languages, you may get lost. The word is
not being its soul.
Yahweh God formed man from the dust of
the ground and breathed into his
nostrils the breath of life and man
became a living soul. That's the key.
That's important. Soul. Why? Because
later on, look what God is going to do.
Now, I hope it translates it
consistently.
See, it didn't do it either. You see,
ah, these translations. Damn. Hold on.
Let me find it.
You can't even find one translation that
gets it right. Like in every place,
right? Only Darby.
Let me see if Darby does it.
I'm trying to find one consistent
translation. Let's see.
[clears throat and cough]
Let's see.
Here you go. Now watch. You ready? Let's
use Darby.
Exactly. Acid. Don't let traditions of
men mislead you. Here's hope for your
animals. And Jehovah Elohim formed man,
dust of the ground, breathed into his
nostrils as breath of life. Man became a
living soul. Now watch. What are animals
and birds? And out of the ground Jehovah
Elohim had formed every animal of the
field and all full of the heavens and
brought them to man to see what he
called them. And whatever man called
each living soul, that was its name.
Same Hebrew words, living soul. So what
are living souls? Animals and birds and
humans. And man gave names to all
cattle, to the fo fowl of the heavens,
and to every beast of the field. But as
for Adam, he found no help make help
like his light. So what are animals and
birds? Living souls. What is man? Living
soul. And let me show you the Hebrew
because I know you guys think I'm lying.
You're a liar, Sam. You're a Bible
perfect, Sam. Don't you know you're an
ecumenist? You ain't representing the
Catholic Church. They they exposed you,
Sam. Yeah, I'm losing sleep. All right.
Nephes,
you should be teaching, Sam, according
to you.
All right, you're going to have to wait.
There you go. Right here. Nephesh.
Nephesh.
Soul living. What about the animals?
What is it? The same Hebrew words. Let's
see.
Let's see. Is it the same Hebrew words?
All right.
Nephesh.
Same Hebrew words. You see it? Let me do
this.
You see it, guys?
Animals, humans,
animals, humans,
birds, living souls. Everyone got it?
Come on, let me know you're getting it.
Rumble, you got it, too. So, that's the
first key. That's the first key.
What about Leviticus 17:10-14 verse 11.
Watch this. What blood do you bring to
the altar? The blood of animals, right?
7 Leviticus 17:10-4 specifically, verse
14. And I'll retitle it. Do animals have
souls?
Let's go to verse 11. So what blood do
they bring on the altar? Do they bring
the blood of humans?
For the soul of the flesh is in the
blood, and I've given it to you upon the
altar to make atonement for your souls.
For it's the blood that maketh atonement
for the soul. Now, okay, he just said
when you bring the blood on the altar,
that's the blood of the animal that you
don't eat. Why? Because the soul of the
flesh is in the blood. Your soul is
connected with your blood. God has
created that as long as there's blood in
your body, your soul remains. If you
drain the blood, the soul has to leave.
But this is talking about the blood of
animals. Why is it saying that their
soul that animates their flesh is
connected with the blood being in their
body? Why are they called souls?
Full context. You want to know? All
right, brother. Here you go. It's right
there. You see it right there.
What blood do you bring on the altar?
The blood of animals and birds. What
blood do you not eat? The blood of the
animals and the birds. Why? Because
their soul that animates their flesh is
connected with the blood. When you drown
the blood, their soul leaves. So by
eating their blood, you're eating their
soul.
Everyone got it before I finish this.
Sinking in. All right. If it's sinking
in that animals and birds have souls.
Animals and birds have souls. And when
you go cam dirt, you better be biblical
man. Your traditions don't matter if
they're not biblical. You still not
convinced. When God drowned the world by
flood, did he drown out animals and
birds and humans?
Genesis 6:17. For I, behold, I bring a
flood of waters on the earth to destroy
all flesh under the heavens, in which is
the breath of life. Wait, the animals
and the birds with humans have the
breath of life in them. Wasn't that the
breath of life that God breathed to
animate Adam? So, not only Adam, but
animals have the breath of life.
Animals are sustained, preserved, and
made alive by the Holy Spirit who gives
them their breath and souls. Yeah. I
mean, if I read my Bible,
he didn't just wipe out human flesh.
You're still not convinced. I know. And
they went to Noah into the ark, two and
two of all flesh, in which was the
breath of life. The two and two that
went in are animals and birds. Yet it
says they have in them the same breath
of life that Adam does.
All right. Here, Genesis 7:22. Now, who
gave them that breath of life to animate
their bodies? Here's the key. Do you
know what Genesis 7:22 literally says?
I'm going to show you the difference.
Here it says breath of life.
Here it says the breath of the spirit of
life, but you don't see it in this
translation. Everything which had in its
nostrils the breath of life of all that
was on the dry land died. Now, did only
animals die? I'm sorry, humans die. No,
animals and birds died. But you know
what this literally says? Let me show
you. You see, you enjoy this. I'm going
deep. It literally says, "All in whose
nostrils was the breath of the spirit of
life."
Now what this means is the breath you
breathe is from the spirit of God who
gives you life. You see the role of the
Holy Spirit. When God breathe that's a
metaphor. He's not a physical being but
that's a metaphor of God sending the
spirit.
And the spirit is called breath. Why?
Because when you think breath you think
life. See it's still part of the
trinity.
Without God's spirit no breath. No
breath no life. So the spirit comes to
then produce in you a soul that the
spirit uses to animate you so you can
breathe and you can live. But here it's
the breath of the spirit of life.
You guys okay that I went in depth on
this? Let me show you the difference in
the terms.
See I had to study this myself. I didn't
want to take the opinions of people. No
animals will have fold. Animals shut the
heck up.
Right now, I already did a session on
this guys. I don't know. But you guys
are creature repetition. You need to
hear something over and over again to
become second nature.
Right?
John 7:22.
Here it is.
What does it say?
The breath from the spirit who gives
life. That's what it means. Now earlier
it said
it didn't say
right here.
And which is
breath of life.
Spirit of life. Okay. The spirit that
gives life.
The spirit that gives you your soul to
breathe.
Now watch here. Now watch again. Let's
go to Genesis 17 and then show you
something.
Watch the connections here. So Genesis
7:15, spirit of life,
those that have life given to them by
the spirit, the Holy Spirit sustains
them. Those who've been given breath by
the spirit who gives life. And elsewhere
it's called
okay
again the spirit of life. So this spirit
gives life.
Now watch here.
I'm going to show you slow slowly.
Let's go here. What is Adam right here?
Now watch the difference in the
terminology.
Adam became what? All right,
right. Why? Because he had the
notice breath here of life that made him
a living soul. Notice elsewhere, Genesis
6:17,
Genesis 7:15, it's called
the spirit of life. But then in Genesis
7:22, it's
the breath of the spirit of life.
You understand what I'm trying to tell
you, right? The life of the animals, of
the birds and humans, is given by the
spirit. And that is the spirit that
gives them the breath to live.
Breath of life, the spirit of life.
The breath from the spirit who gives
life,
right?
We making these connections. Okay,
everyone make the connection. Why here
it's
breath of life. Why? In Genesis 6:17,
spirit of life, but Genesis 7:22, it's
the breath of the spirit of life.
Because here, the Bible is explaining to
you,
right?
That it is the Holy Spirit that gives
you life. And it's the Holy Spirit that
gives you the breath so you can live.
You see the role of the Holy Spirit,
right? I hope I didn't bore you guys
with this level of detail. Now, do they
have spirits? I showed you they have
souls. They're living souls. Souls
produced by the spirit who gave them
life, who gave them breath to to live
just like Adam. But do they have ru
spirit? Okay, let's go. Ecclesiastes 3:1
19-21.
For that which happens to the sons of
men happens to animals. He's asking the
question, can we know apart from
revelation? If all I do is I observe the
world and I see the world.
Am I able to know where the spirit of a
man goes when he dies? And does it go to
a different place than the spirit of an
animal? No. So he's talking about human
observation apart from revelation. So
for that which happens to the sons of
men happens to animals. Even one thing
happens to them. As the one dies, so the
other dies. Yes, they all have one
breath. We're going to see what that
means. And man has no advantage over the
animals. For all is vanity. All go to
one place. All are from dust and turn to
dust again. Now that we can see we all
go to dust. But now watch here. Who
knows the spirit of man whether it goes
upward and the spirit of the animal
whether it goes downward to the earth.
You see just like he he doesn't deny man
has a spirit he's also aware animals
have a spirit because the same breath
animates us.